this episode of real engineering is
brought to you by brilliant a problem
solving website that teaches you to
think like an engineer one of the
biggest challenges facing mankind today
is our quest to transition to renewable
energy overhauling our entire
electricity grid requires drastic
changes to be made in the way we produce
transport use and store electricity we
have explored in past videos that with
the lowering cost of solar and wind
we are beginning to hit a point of
imbalance in the grid where places like
California are wasting massive amounts
of energy in the summer months when
solar is at its peak and not producing
enough in winter to deal with this
problem California is now installing
gigantic battery storage facilities in
places like Moss Landing to store that
excess for later use but the amount of
battery storage that they will require
as our percentage of renewables
increases is going to cost the state
billions if not trillions we could
drastically decrease this dependence on
batteries if we could find a nice stable
energy source that did not harm our
planet some want to turn to nuclear
energy but what if I told you this
solution may be lying directly under our
feet imagine an ancient hidden energy
source deep within every square meter of
our planet's surface it's clean flexible
virtually limitless completely renewable
never turns off and virtually carbon
free geothermal energy is produced by
the Earth's inherent heat the center of
the earth is as hot as the surface of
the Sun through convection that heat
warms the outer layers of the planet but
where does that heat come from much of
it comes from gravitational forces when
the planet first formed four billion
years ago some heat is generated from
friction as denser elements make their
way to the Earth's core the other source
of Earth's internal heat occurs in the
upper mantle and crust where the decay
of radioactive isotopes like
potassium-40
creates energy and in turn heat if we
could find a way to safely and
cost-effectively access that heat our
energy problems would be solved in year
that he does come to the surface in some
easily accessible locations at
temperatures of 700 degrees or more
rocks become partially melted becoming
magma driving a variety of geothermal
phenomena if magma flowing underground
heats gases or water it can create
bubbling hot springs and geysers
undersea hot vents and natural steam
vents these features can provide water
that's more than 200 degrees more than
enough to run a steam turbine geothermal
hot spots like this are found near the
boundaries of tectonic plates like
Iceland in volcanic Li active areas like
Turkey or in some places where the
Earth's crust is thin like America's
Yellowstone National Park these places
provide low hanging fruit to harvest the
Earth's heat for our energy needs each
year enough heat flows to the planet's
surface to meet our total global energy
consumption twice over and the
geothermal reservoir is boundless heat
within 10 kilometres of Earth's surface
contains roughly 50,000 times more
energy than all fossil fuel resources
worldwide yes geothermal energy makes up
less than 1% of global installed
electricity capacity this isn't even a
technology issue of the global potential
for geothermal power using off-the-shelf
technology only 7% has been tapped so in
the fight to transform our global energy
system why haven't we adopted this
energy source in a serious way
let's first look at our low-hanging
fruit that are not being used to their
full potential naturally occurring
hydrothermal reservoirs feature hot
water that percolates near the surface
through porous or cracked rock layers
this is the easiest form of geothermal
energy to harvest and can be tapped in
several ways which we've been doing for
centuries human societies have used the
heat from low-temperature geothermal
energy for millennia among the most
famous examples may be the hot springs
of Bath England established by Roman
engineers in 60 seee here 1 million
liters of water percolates to the city
center of bath
every day at a temperature of about 45
degrees heating recreational baths and
heating some buildings this hot water
replenishes itself as rain that falls in
nearby hills seeps through porous
limestone deep underground where it is
heated and rises back to the surface but
convenient locations like this where the
right combination of a water cycle with
porous rocks underground and a heat
source close enough to the surface to
heat it are rare and ones that can
provide water with enough heat and
pressure to run a steam turbine are even
rarer this particular source is not
suitable as 45 degrees as far off the
lowest temperature we can employ there
are three basic types of geothermal
energy generators all three share the
same basic idea take hot water or steam
from a geothermal reservoir and run it
through a steam turbine where it loses
energy and condenses before being pumped
back underground to keep the cycle going
dry steam generators take the steam
directly from the source to run the
turbine a flash steam power plant takes
extremely hot water under pressure above
100 degrees and expands it quickly to
lower its boiling point and turn it to
steam to run the steam turbine these
both require higher temperature sources
that are rare but a relatively common in
geothermally active regions like Iceland
Italy Austria and around the Pacific
Ring of Fire and in these locations
geothermal energy is common and is
expected to grow as much as 28% in the
next four years with countries in
Southeast Asia expected to see the
largest growths like Indonesia and the
Philippines but we want to exploit
geothermal energy outside of these
regions no matter how much power we
extract we can't transport it fair
before power losses due to resistance in
the cables saps it away the third type
of generator provides the highest
potential for expanding geothermal
energy as it can utilize the lowest
temperature sources this system is
called a binary cycle system in a binary
cycle power plant warm water from a
geothermal source passes through a heat
exchanger where
as heat with a closed loop containing a
fluid with a low boiling point like
pentane which has a boiling point of 36
degrees the lower boiling point allows
it to transition to a gas at a much
lower temperature allowing it to run a
turbine at a lower temperature this
system has allowed countries like
Germany which lacks any shallow depth
geothermal resources to grow their
geothermal energy market in recent years
where temperatures as low as 100 degrees
Celsius being utilized that figure is
important because the higher the
temperature the deeper we have to drill
different areas have different
geothermal gradients which is a measure
of how quickly temperatures rise as we
drill down this map shows a rough
estimate of the geothermal gradient
across the US with the highest gradients
been found in Oregon and Idaho reaching
as high as 70 degrees per kilometer this
is important as to access this heat in
areas where it doesn't naturally come to
the surface in an accessible way we need
to drill down and the further we need to
drill the more expensive it becomes
typically we have only used geothermal
resources where the natural permeability
of the rocks allows a convective heat
cycle but a new technology by the name
of enhanced geothermal systems or EGS
may open the door to geothermal energy
in more regions it works like this the
first step is to drill an injection well
into a formation of hot rocks then
engineers inject fluid at pressure to
form cracks or enlarge existing ones
this increases the area over which heat
exchange with the rocks can occur to
increase this area even further a
non-toxic and degradable material is
pumped down to fill these cracks and
allow the pressure to form new cracks as
we drill further down once we have
opened an adequate number of passages
for the water to fill we can drill
additional holes that can act as an
outlet for our hot water as we pump more
underground a report by MIT in 2006
found that EGS could provide electricity
at a cost as low as three point nine
cents per kilowatt-hour roughly
equivalent to a coal-fired power plant
the united states government
esta
it's that new geothermal power plants
could produce 60 gigawatts of electric
power on American soil by 2050 mostly
through EGS systems now I know what you
are thinking this sounds a lot like the
controversial practice of fracking but
it doesn't use toxic fracking fluid
which can seep into our water cycle it
uses water and some safe additives but
it's not all plain sailing to make this
work we need to create great volumes of
fractures and cracks and this can have
some disastrous consequences in 2017
drilling at a proposed site for EGS in
Pohang south korea is thought to have
triggered an earthquake of 5.4 magnitude
that injured 135 people a previous
incident occurred at an EGS plant in
Basel Switzerland in 2006 when drilling
may have caused the quake of magnitude
3.4 and several buildings were damaged
both projects were cancelled as a result
red tape is a huge obstacle for
geothermal energy in the United States
for example there's less environmental
paper work and fewer approvals required
for drilling for oil than drilling a
geothermal well tax credits for wind and
solar power projects are 30 percent
while the tax credit for geothermal is
only 10 percent on top of all this
drilling is very expensive and as we
have seen doesn't guarantee a successful
geothermal plant you could waste months
of your time digging a two kilometre
hole in the ground and the productivity
of the well could be too small to make
the project worthwhile this makes it
difficult to find investors willing to
bet their money on it it simply makes
more sense to invest in solar and wind
despite the challenges there's real hope
for expanding geothermal energy the
industry can build off of recent
improvements in drilling technology
engineers are developing new kinds of
drills for geothermal wells and better
techniques for cementing wells drilled
into hot rocks the earthquake risk is
real but engineers have protocols for
monitoring with seismometers to ensure
that the seismic risk can be assessed
early on in the case of the Bassel
accident the EGS facility was located
over a seismic fault
due to the proximity of hot rocks to the
surface once the shaking started fluid
injection was halted immediately so far
geothermal projects haven't attracted
strong political support in the West
both they also haven't managed to draw
major opposition suggesting that easing
permitting rules for the technology may
not be so challenging as commercial
interest in this clean energy source
Rises political support force should
follow especially if some smart
politician realizes that it can be a
rallying call for getting out of work
oil drilling texts back to work
sometimes the struggle to convert the
global energy system to renewables can
seem out of reach and feel hopeless but
in the case of geothermal energy there's
an exciting source of electricity and
heat that could power our future and
it's right below our feet as I said at
the start of the video much of the
energy present within the earth is
formed as a result of gravitational
forces you can learn everything gravity
is capable of by taking this course on
brilliant this course will take you from
the very basics of what gravity is and
build your knowledge up to the point of
being able to apply Kepler's laws of
planetary motion and understand orbital
mechanics like using the slingshot
effect where spaceships use a planet's
gravity to increase their speed it's a
fascinating course that I can't
recommend enough or you could complete
one of brains daily challenges each day
brilliant presents you with interesting
scientific and mathematical problems to
test your brain each daily challenge
provides you with the context and
framework that you will need to tackle
it so that you can learn the concepts by
applying them if you like the problem
and want to learn more there's a course
quiz that explores the same concept in
greater detail if you are confused and
need more guidance there's a community
of thousands of learners discussing the
problems and writing solutions daily
challenges are thought-provoking
challenges that will lead you from
curiosity to mastery one day at a time
if I have inspired you and you want to
educate yourself then go to brilliant
org ford slash
real engineering and sign up for free
and the first 500 people that go to that
link
we'll get 20% off the annual premium
subscription so you can get full access
to all their courses as well as the
entire daily challenges archive as
always thanks for watching and thank you
to all my patreon supporters if you'd
like to see more from me the links to my
Instagram Twitter subreddit and discord
server are below